[MUSIC PLAYING]
Good morning, everyone.
I'm Andy.
I'm going to be talking
to you about scaling
to the next billion players.
I'm on the product marketing
team for Google Cloud Platform.
So mobile and cloud
are better together.
If you think of today's
most compelling apps,
whether it's Uber or Spotify,
Netflix, YouTube, or even Maps,
the most compelling content
treats client and cloud
as a single platform.
And nowhere is this more
dramatic than games.
And this is going
to date me, but I
spent 10 years of my adolescence
playing these multiuser
dimensions, multiuser dungeons.
We're talking 9,600 baud
modems dialing up to BBSs.
And as modest as the user
interface was for these,
it's amazing how
much they got right.
It's amazing how much they
understood their medium.
Things like a very in-depth
community, a guild system,
precursor to modern
day MMOs, your identity
within the community
was a huge reason
for players to come back.
Live daily events-- some
of these were goofy.
On Thanksgiving Day, they
had turkeys running around
where you could loot.
They would drop gold and armor.
But it was just text, and
admins could orchestrate
all of that on the server side.
And every day had something new
for players to come back to.
Very Minecraft-esque, an
infinite world of UGC.
I built a zone called
Valley of the Jedi Tower,
and 15 years later,
it still stands.
All the NPCs, mobs, gear,
all the room descriptions,
it's still there today.
And players,
non-engineers, being
able to put content
back into the game
was huge and was expected.
So I think you
guys get the idea.
Fast forward to today, it's
a different era for gaming.
The stats for this are
all over the place.
It's going to vary.
But one source, GSMA, puts 6
billion folks with smartphones
in the next four to five years.
These folks, coming
online for the first time,
they're doing it through these
Playstations in their pockets,
gaming great
devices, that's going
to be their first
experience with gaming.
And along the same theme,
the other side of the coin
is ubiquitous cloud
access, 4G connectivity,
broadband connectivity on the go
where, in developed countries,
we're talking 100% coverage
and, in developing countries,
right at the tipping point
where the majority of folks
are going to have 4G coverage,
that combination of mobile
and cloud together is
going to make the player
experience greater than
the sum of the parts.
I'm going to back up.
If you were to take something
away from this short lining
talk, what Google Cloud
Platform is trying to do
is to enable these great
foundational gaming experiences
in a way where the complexity
doesn't cause the whole house
of cards to collapse.
In other words, if you're
bringing the same complexity
from the olden days
to the new mediums,
you're bringing forth
all this baggage.
So the one idea to take away is
we succeed-- our north star--
success for us is if you're
able to focus on content.
Every waking second, focus on
content and not infrastructure.
And this is an eye chart,
but Google Cloud Platform
is a collection of
services and, really,
across compute,
storage, and analytics
we have a range of
abstractions, and the magic
is in choosing the
right abstraction.
Abstraction's like being able
to have something fully managed.
It's hard to see here,
but, in this case,
you're just focusing on the
content of your game, the state
of your persistent game world.
You just have a blob of
content in one line of code.
It writes it globally
across all gaming platforms
you care about.
The mutation is heard, and via
callback, they know about it.
You don't have to manage
any infrastructure.
You don't have to spin up any
VMs, spin up any REST services.
It just works.
So across compute,
storage, and analytics,
we have these-- what we call
third wave services that
allow you to focus
on your content,
and mere mortals like myself,
scripters, can go and put
content into the game.
Realizing that not everyone can
start with wave three services,
you can have your
existing stack today,
have it run on top of Google's
world class infrastructure.
So Google Cloud Platform is
allowing you to take your stack
or using our cloud
native services
and run it on top of
Google's infrastructure.
With that, I'm at time.
And I'd like to invite
you to check out
cloud.google.com/products.
[MUSIC PLAYING]